the third on the list is sentiment analysis
this often would help businesses review feedback from customers
so rather than feedback just coming in
or tickets just coming in randomly
you could tell the mood the tone
the expectation of a customer
when their message drops within your mailbox
when you know the message that comes in
you can route it to the person who is likely to solve the problem
rather than just leaving messages the way they arrive
just like that
and finally on my list is image classification
building a model that can identify objects
animals whatever it is
this is very important especially if you're interested
in working with robotics or industrial machine
because at the end of the day
you be required to identify one item or the other
so the question is back to you
which of the project do you think we should be
just let me know in the comment section
the resources will be available
you can follow along how those things will be done
and you can ask me question
my goal is to simplify some of this terminology
in such a way that you be learning something technical
but at the end of the day you don't feel it
you feel like you're just listening to some simple information
and that's how we run it here
if this is helpful
leave me a comment and subscribe to my social media platform
until next time I'll see you in the next one